talk to me welcome to the heavy spoilers
show I'm your host Paul in this video
we're breaking down talk to me the brand
new horror is one of my favorite films
of the air and throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down the
hidden layers and details that you might
have missed
you win we'll also be talking about the
true meaning of the ending and
explaining all the Thematic things in it
that they do throughout the film I don't
want to just recap the story so if
you're coming into this video I'm
assuming that you've already seen it but
I will do a little bit of setup to add
some context in case you haven't however
I highly recommend that you check it out
before this video and if you enjoy it
then make sure you subscribe
[Music]
now the movie was distributed by a24 and
it follows a teenager named Mia who gets
a little too up close and personal at a
party with some Spirits normally when I
do that it leads to me face down in a
bathtub somewhere but Mia and her
friend's brother Riley are pulled into a
horrifying world of ghosts and ghouls I
feel like the whole movie is kind of a
comment on the old thing people used to
do at parties such as breaking out a
Ouija board or playing Bloody Mary
initially the hand seems like it's all
fun and games and it's something we know
due to the ending goes on worldwide I
like all good Goats games There are
rules that shouldn't be broken and for
this part of the video I want to go
through what the rules are holding the
hand and saying talk to me allows the
person to connect with the spirit and
they can sit there and talk to them or
take things beyond that if they say I
let you in it allows the spirit to
possess them and talk to those in the
room which is it's a little bit creepy
isn't it now it's possible for the
spirits to gain more control unless the
connection must be severed in 90 seconds
to stop this from happening as Hayley
explains a candle used at the start of
the event must be blown out and this
will stop the spirits from taking
complete control this is something that
used to be a staple of seances as well
with mediums carrying out similar acts
to what we see here candles would be lit
in some circumstances and they'd also
allow themselves to get possessed but
well depending on on what you believe
now the spirits we encounter all seem to
have suffered grave or unfair fate and
thus they covet the living and want to
hold on to them as long as they can from
what we see of the afterlife it's a grim
fate where you're unable to interact
with anyone and thus the handmade makes
them feel somewhat like they've managed
to come back
[Music]
I call paranormal civil not all
paranormal stuff but you know stuff
seems to start off as awful and games
and the group Cedars entertainment
rather than it being how horrific it
actually is everyone whips out their
phones and I feel like this may be a
comment on how mobiles and cameras have
kind of detached us from reality it's
easy to feel like you're not actually
part of it when you're watching things
happen in the moment through a screen
and things are so fun you'll probably
end up laughing and dancing to your
favorite Crazy Frog ringtone
everything
[Music]
however things hit a wall when Riley
connects with me as deceased mother who
we learned attitude what she's being
told was an accidental overdose but
father somewhat shuts this down later by
reading her a no but Mia was never
really able to get the closure that she
wanted on this situation a strained
relationship with her father is shown us
perfectly when we first see the pair
together as he shot out of focus showing
they aren't really connected you also
get Mia having to turn a tap on and off
to talk to him and water actually plays
a big part in the film suddenly that our
actors lace it through a lot of shots
and appears at numerous times throughout
the entire movie the sound of water can
be heard from the first spirit that
possesses me air and we also learned
that she died because of drowning
talk to me
shortly after rain washes the window
whilst Riley and Mia talk and this
creates an effect like the pair are
being splashed with water later on when
Mia gets in the car with Daniel we also
see his Reign hits the windshield and it
carries on this idea blood runs down the
shower under the drain with Riley and
there's also rain at the hospital when
Jade goes to her mother there's also the
effect of water covering the ghosts and
it's something that we see continue
throughout the film I think this
connection to the first ghost well the
second one the first one that possesses
her show she's always with mere and once
they've connected there's water
surrounding her because she may always
be watching Mirrors in glass also play a
big part 2 with Mia's mother mainly
being shot through reflective surfaces
this is something that The Shining most
notably did as well and all the scenes
involving ghosts either had glass or
mirrors in them this is the case when
she first sees her behind the door and
we can catch him while they're standing
behind some corrugated glass at the
hospital Mira also catches her
reflection in a hallway window before
she goes into the bathroom which is of
course line with mirrors here She Bangs
on the cubicle doors to try and get it
open which is actually similar what
happened with her mother's death we
learned that after she passed away her
body slumped in front of the door and
her dad had to show the barge through it
in order to get to her this is something
that he has to do to get into Mia's room
later on and it plays off both the past
and foreshadows the future when her dad
reads her the note we also see her
mother's reflection in the window and
when talking to her in her room this
happens through a mirror this somewhat
Rifts on a conversation earlier on when
Jade spoke with her mom through a mirror
as well is that is aoin anyway it all
culminates at the end when Mia comes
face to face with a mirror at the
hospital which we'll talk more about
later on in the video now in the case of
Riley's you did everything with Mia's
mother the link goes past 90 seconds and
he starts to smash his head like it's
the like button
hospitalized mirrors haunted by visions
of her mother and both Riley's sister
and Mum blame her for his injuries
taking the hand Mia uses it to reconnect
with her mother who tells her that her
death wasn't accidental she also tells
her that she needs to kill Riley in
order to save him and that she will take
care of him when he gets into the
Afterlife now if you're asking me that
was a [__] lie we know the ghosts can
change shapes you don't want appearing
like Mia's dad and as we know Mia's
mother also left a note I was kind of
expecting I'll be honest with you I'm a
bit stupid but I was kind of expecting
the twist to be that he killed her
mother but I'm glad they strayed away
from it and honestly he seemed like a
good guy I think the visions of limbo
that mere sees when connecting with
Riley that's the truth of the matter and
when her mother's uttering will have him
forever at the end it shows what her
true plan is I actually believe that
she's the one who killed Mia and that
she's been manipulating her for the
entire time I don't think it's Mia's
mother I think it's someone
shape-shifting as her and basically
using lies to manipulate the character
now it could be seen as them winning
however she didn't do enough in the end
to make her kill Riley and this is why
he's freed and let go in the finale now
this is somewhat foreshadowed to us at
the start of the movie when we see the
brothers duckett and coal together at
the house party Duckett stabs Cole and
he doesn't dock it before saying dock it
and ending his own life sorry now this
is a similar thing to what happens with
Mia and therefore I think the spirits
were the ones that had a hand in it now
Mia being unable to kill Riley actually
plays into her character as we see what
her true nature is like due to the
kangaroo in the road this is somewhat a
metaphor for Riley as both Lay Dying and
Mia has a choice to make both instances
involve cars and driving at high speed
which I actually appreciate in terms of
the symbolism on both cases she can't
put them out of their misery and this
shows that she'd always struggle when
killing Riley or Riley getting to walk
away from this was actually set up by
Cole on the bus who told them that the
spirit's hold would weaken on its own we
don't actually have any evidence for
this but be on this scene with Riley and
I know there is some contention over it
as the spirits do seem to get stronger
and we know what happened with his
brother let me know your thoughts below
though but either way Mia didn't really
want to believe this because she wanted
to trust the girls that appeared to be
her mother as for what the girls to want
there appears to be a contradiction in
their motives for example they longed to
be in possession of someone and can be
seen laughing singing and enjoying
themselves for the best 90 seconds of
their life that's something my wife says
she enjoys as well and you'd think that
the spirits wouldn't want to kill Riley
if they have possession over him however
they clearly lust for his soul and this
is seen from the initial possession and
also them coveting him I'm guessing due
to what we see with limbo they have sick
and twisted desires that make younger
Souls much more appealing potentially
you are also experiencing not only
ghosts of the living but I also think
there could be demons as well I think if
you're going with that mindset then the
motives make much more sense but yeah
again let me know and I promise this
isn't just bait to make you comment on
the video and the possessions themselves
do seem demonic too with a person's eyes
becoming blacker the longer it goes on
the eyes are of course windows to the
soul so retaining possession could end
up taking one's Soul now they may just
be ghosts though and let's be honest
living in a black void for eternity
where he used as a party trick might get
annoying after about five minutes you
might just hit a point where you want to
bring everyone down with you and if you
had end games spoiled for you you might
want to spoil end game for everyone else
talking about myself there but either
way Mia's death gives a harrowing
version of the afterlife and it reflects
a dream she talked about earlier in the
movie she stated that she had one where
she was unable to see her reflection and
sadly this happens come the end of the
film she's once more shut out again from
her father and again this speaks to the
separation that's going on between them
sadly he's lost both his wife and
daughter now and this is due to the pair
taking their own lives or at least
seeming to I feel like this is sort of
the true meaning of the film with death
lingering on forever about long after
someone is gone that was the case with
Mia's mum and though she saved Riley
She's now A specter Force to look on
whilst those around her miss her she'll
also be pulled out by others who see the
fun in death but ultimately if they were
to encounter it like she had there would
be a totally different story it's not
the enchanting thing the characters
think and the horror that the spirits
are going through isn't something to be
mocked or laughed at I feel like this is
what mere experiences at the end and we
see her moving towards a light which is
normally a sign of going to heaven or
that there's no happiness here or
reunion with her mother and instead
she's wheeled out of the party to become
a trick that she herself mocked we know
the hand itself has been passed around
too as we can see graffiti and
signatures on it showing how many owners
it's had I think every group likely
gives it away when something happens to
them similar to duck and Emir and it may
end up trapping those who mock it to
live the Fate themselves it feels like
bitter irony and it speaks to how death
and tragedy can turn a living into that
themselves because they're unable to let
go that's what I think the hand
symbolizes and this was all started
because Mia couldn't let go of her
mother within Riley had she accepted her
life and that she needed to live it
herself then she wouldn't live in this
eternal death constantly experiencing
what we see her going through Mia has
now made a similar fate to her and now
Riley's off Living Well the life of
Riley she's stuck in this eternal
torment unable to move on I think this
film talks about grief guilt and blame
with her jumping from emotion to emotion
throughout the entire piece she
obviously Grieves and feels guilt over
her mother but at times she also blames
her father too I think the movie may
even trick us into thinking that that's
the way it's gonna go so we somewhat
blame him as well and can put ourselves
in mere shoes mere even lives with Jade
and her family and she's got a way
closer bond with them than her dad due
to what's happened it also shows that
the darker sides of our mind all
entities May Prey Upon grief and Mia was
manipulated throughout this due to her
feelings and she and my father talked
earlier she could have avoided this fate
instead of wondering what the truth was
which led her yeah it's a really dark
and depressing ending especially when
you start to think about it and it
closes out what's an incredible film
made by two YouTubers it's kind of kind
of put me to shame a bit and we know
that the second film is actually
currently in the works I really think
there's lots of interesting Concepts
that they can do with this and rather
than following another group I actually
hope that we stick with Mia I think it'd
be interesting to see her almost acting
like a guardian angel to Riley as I
doubt the spirits of let him go that
easily I think we could use Mir as a way
to explain the spirit and what goes on
as well and also where the Han
originally came from we did get attached
upon with it being linked to a medium
but there may be a way for us to see its
history and what's gone on with it time
clearly moves differently in the Land of
the Dead as I'm guessing what is a month
seems to pass by in seconds we also get
people speaking in a foreign language
showing that the hand at least would
have had to travel some distance I think
she may even possess this person and
then try to use them as a way to reach
out to our old friends which I think
would be devastating if she learns it's
been years and years you may even get an
older Riley who shows up looking like
Terry Tibbs and then we could get the
best joke of all time when he says hello
wooden ladders talk to my bib now all in
all that wraps up the movie but I have
to say I really enjoyed it can't wait to
see what happens next time and if
there's anything we miss below then drop
it in the comments as I'd love to read
your thoughts please hit the Thumbs Up
Button while you're down there and if
you want to join the channel as a member
of the spoiler Society then please click
the join button you'll get early access
to videos every week and it goes such a
long way to helping us do what we love
and bring these videos to you if you
want to support the channel and get some
heavy spoilers merch we've also got a
t-shirt line located just below the
video that will let you pick up all
kinds of tops like I got a theory time
one house of the Dragon stuff Marvel
teas and a lot more we drop new designs
on there almost every month so yeah
definitely keep an eye out for them and
again and thank you everyone who's
bought one now if you want something
else to watch you've got a breakdown of
another Australian horror and that is
the babadook which will be linked on
screen right now get super deep on the
movie talk about all the themes in it
and definitely head over there right
after this about the way huge thank you
for singing through the video I've been
Paul I'll see you next time take care
peace